data generation and capture isn't a
problem today with an astonishing growth
in the last few years
the world's annual data generation is to
reach a whopping 175 zettabytes by 2025
but having just a lot of data can't be
the answer to everything companies
around the world today are struggling to
make sense of all that data
and extracting as much value from it as
possible and what they need now
are data scientists professionals with
skill sets and industry acumen to device
algorithms and techniques that can make
real-time insights and data validated
decisions
a reality imagine if you could become
the one they seek with all the skills
and applied knowledge and an endorsement
from a top university on your cv
without ever having to leave your job or
home in the most hands-on boot camp that
there is
welcome to simply learn's postgraduate
program in data science
in partnership with purdue university
the number one data science course as
ranked by economic times
also in collaboration with one of the
world's foremost innovators in the data
science space
ibm deep dive into a cutting-edge
curriculum
and an industry-relevant learning path
championing the most job-critical data
technologies
tools and skills are python programming
machine learning nlp data visualization
with tableau
and much more learn by doing and also
from the best
get hands-on in the most immersive
learning experience
in an eight times higher live
interaction global cohort with live
online classes
by top data practitioners master classes
by purdue faculty
and experts at ibm exclusive ibm
hackathons
and ask me anything sessions 25 plus
real-life projects
with industry data sets from amazon uber
etc
and a final capstone and three domains
to showcase your readiness for the job
at your dream employer what's more our
newly launched simply learn career
service in india and the us
bridges the gap between you and your
professional goals
with resume makeovers one-on-one
interviews
and getting your profile noticed by top
hiring companies
as soon as you complete your
certification and once you're done
armed with the game-changing purdue
post-graduation program certification
industry recognized ibm certificates for
the ibm courses
and membership to the prestigious purdue
alumni association
take on your new career chasing and
realizing those dreams that have
mattered to you the most
fill out a two-minute application form
and our consultant will be in touch with
the prerequisites
here's to a glorious future together
we're excited to meet you
at our next cohort